[Music]
Augsburg marijuana on this Monday night
this Ontario Rail blockade finally
dismantle who was detained and what
happens next we can both protect
reconciliation and protect Canada's
economy plus when will full rail service
resumed breaking news out of Alberta a
court rules the federal carbon tax is
unconstitutional where this leaves
climate policy as a proposal for another
massive oil sands mine is pulled italy's
sudden surge of koban 19 cases
picturesque towns now quarantine zones
and she was number one celebrating
mathematician Catrin Johnson and her
winning equation for success
global national with Donna freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin tonight with breaking news on
multiple fronts all of it related to
resource projects in this country caught
in the tension over climate policy and
indigenous rights late today the Alberta
Court of Appeal ruled the federal carbon
tax is unconstitutional that it can't be
imposed by the federal government a
victory for Alberta's premier we
promised albertans that we would fight
this federal carbon tax we kept our
promise and today we've succeeded we'll
get you more on that in just a moment
but also today tech frontier bailed on
its plan to build a 20 billion dollar
oil sands mine in northern Alberta
and in Tyendinaga Ontario at least one
train along the CN Rail line did start
moving today after 19 days of blockades
Vancouver those sympathizers with the
widtsoe itand chiefs have gathered at
this key intersection during the rush
hour blocking access to the Port of
Vancouver demonstrators were also here
two weeks ago prompting the port to get
a court injunction to remove them
protesters are also blocking rail tracks
in nearby Maple Ridge tonight forcing
the cancellation of the West Coast
Express train service and this is just
after 8 a.m. in Ontario dozens of
Ontario provincial police officers moved
in to end the blockade near Belleville a
handful of protesters who shut down
passenger and freight trains were
arrested they were supporting a small
group of what so it and hereditary
chiefs in northern BC who don't want the
coastal gas link natural gas pipeline
crossing their territory
those chiefs are talking to the RCMP
about removing a police outpost and seem
willing to consider meeting federal
ministers if that happens the Prime
Minister says it proves his strategy is
working we demonstrated through this
process that we can both protect
reconciliation and protect Canada's
economy as we move forward we'll get to
the political challenge all this poses
in just a moment but first
David akin on what happened at the rail
blockade when the police moved in a
midnight deadline to clear the blockade
came and went and as dawn broke on
Tyendinaga the blockade and its
protesters remained in place
but not for long at about 8 a.m. local
time
a convoy of police vehicles move to the
barricade the protesters themselves
streamed what happened next on their
Facebook page an OPP community liaison
officer asked the protesters once more
to leave but the protesters are defiant
you leave and then after a short speech
from one of them
a confrontation and arrests police
arrested 10 people on different charges
all were taken away in special police
vehicles they would be later released
with conditions and by day's end back
near the main blockade camp dozens of
community members and others gathered in
support of those protestors
I'm just really ashamed of Canada and
the treatment of indigenous people still
ongoing to this day in 2020 it's just
kind of disgusting meanwhile back in BC
that what's so it and wait for
confirmation that the RCMP have indeed
left their territory confirmation that
could prompt the Mohawks and their
supporters entiendo Nega to finally
stand down as for the trains it's not
clear when regular service will resume
both CN and via want to have that happen
as soon as possible
CN crews were on the tracks as soon as
the blockade was lifted checking to make
sure the tracks were safe and free of
damage Donna all right and some trains
are moving tonight david aiken on
Tyendinaga territory in ontario thanks
rail service may finally be getting back
to normal but the small group of what so
it in hereditary Chiefs still don't want
a pipeline through their territory
even though 20 elected band councils
have consented to it as Michael Couture
reports that crisis is still looming
inside the House of Commons and outside
on the streets
hundreds of protesters shut down parts
of downtown Ottawa as they marched in
solidarity with with certain hereditary
Chiefs signs like reconciliation is dead
signal this is about more than the
natural gas pipeline in northern BC the
economic impact has yet to be measured
as trains sat idle but it's been blunted
somewhat according to prime minister
justin trudeau so we've been working
with rail carriers to ensure that many
trains continue to use alternate routes
to get through and that's one of the
reasons we've been able to avoid some of
the most serious serious shortages there
have been concerns about critical
shortages of chlorine and propane which
are normally moved by rail and
opposition parties say the Prime
Minister's lack of action for more than
two weeks has paved the way for future
protesters there is now a clear playbook
for radical activists to follow and they
know that the Prime Minister will do
literally nothing as the economy is
brought to its knees the government says
it's committed to addressing the
concerns of the wets Odin hereditary
Chiefs who want to stop the gas pipeline
project and want the RCMP off their land
the Mounties have left an outpost and
that seen as a possible breakthrough we
needed them to communicate that that was
to their satisfaction to their
supporters coast to coast to coast
unfortunately that didn't happen but
that Safety Office is closed
what's oats and hereditary chiefs were
expected to verify the RCMP s withdrawal
themselves instead other protests
continue to pop up across the country
we're worth not only fighting days of
suspicion and mistrust but decades in
and even centuries in some cases which
is exactly why everyone on all sides is
thinking about what happens now and for
decades to come
Michael accretor Global News Ottawa
now to Alberta and watt premier Jason
Kenney calls good news and bad news
first the carbon tax in a four to one
decision the Alberta Court of Appeal
ruled federal carbon pricing is
unconstitutional the Alberta government
argued a federally imposed carbon tax
was a stepping stone that would allow
to interfere in provincial sovereignty
the court agreed calling it a Trojan
horse heather murex west joins me from
calgary tonight heather tell us more
about the ruling and what it means well
Donna this isn't the first time that a
province has challenged the federal
carbon tax but it is the first time a
province has won courts in both
Saskatchewan and Ontario upheld the tax
last year and of course this is frame
court well here Saskatchewan appeal this
spring the federal Environment Minister
says audible will wait to see what the
Supreme Court ultimately decides but
says he feels confident that the federal
position will be upheld
Alberta's premier however disagrees
maintaining that provinces Chev
jurisdiction when it comes to planning
climate policies Donna all right thanks
Heather and we'll come back to you in
just a moment the other big story in
Alberta is about tech frontier it's
pulled the plug on a huge oil sands
project in Alberta just before the
federal cabinet was poised to give it a
final yes or no it had support from
indigenous communities and it passed all
environmental reviews yet the company's
CEO said there is no constructive path
forward
Donn's Lindsay says global capital
markets are changing rapidly and
investors and customers are increasingly
looking for jurisdictions to have a
framework in place that reconciles
resource development and climate change
in order to produce the cleanest
possible products and Maddie says
doesn't exist in Canada to be viable
this project also needed higher oil
prices more pipeline capacity and more
foreign investors it's another sign
Canadian political leaders need to stop
fighting and work together on a coherent
climate policy
here's Heather's report on that the
massive frontier mine proposal was seen
as a beacon of hope for this small
oilfield servicing company there were no
real major projects that were being
announced to hear the news this morning
I think was really devastating for for a
lot of people tech resources spent nine
years and a billion dollars working the
oil sands mega project through Canada's
regulatory process it had the support of
indigenous communities in the region and
despite questions around whether the
project would be financially viable with
oil down to 50 US dollars a barrel the
company believed it would be
commercially viable instead in his
letter to the federal Environment
Minister Sunday Tech's CEO Don Lindsay
placed blame on the political
uncertainty around climate policy
and the energy sector the promise of
Canada's potential will not be realized
until governments can reach agreement
around how climate policy considerations
will be addressed without clarity on
this critical question it will be very
difficult to attract future investment
it's going to take some strong and clear
leadership to send a different message
to global investors because right now
it's pretty easy to see this as a
negative on the end of a string of
negatives Alberta's premier who has been
calling on Ottawa to approve the tech
mine since December has been quick to
place blame on the federal government
but the federal Environment Minister
says he agrees with the points raised by
tech that all levels of government need
to get on the same page we agree and we
say we are taking strong action on
climate change we need to be working to
collaborate with all of the provinces
and territories we need to be all on the
same page not fighting with each other
all over the price on pollution and
those kinds of things we need to be
working together and there is support
for a carbon tax across the energy
industry tech CEO stated that support in
his letter Sunday the Canadian
Association of Petroleum Producers
reiterated that support today as well
it's were only really only a small group
of provincial Conservative premiers
Donna that are opposed right heather
York's West in Calgary tonight thanks
this balance between energy growth
environmental policy and indigenous
rights poses a big challenge for
political leaders federal and provincial
our Ottawa bureau chief Mercedes
Stevenson joins me Mercedes there's a
lot of anger a lot of finger-pointing
and now this Alberta Court of Appeal
ruling that the carbon tax is
unconstitutional where does this leave
the prime minister well Donna it's
another challenge for Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau who is face test after
test of his leadership and government
since being reelected and today's carbon
tax decision adds to that mess playing
into heated partisan rhetoric across the
country mr. Trudeau was elected on three
key promises the environment the economy
and reconciliation and now all three of
those priorities are colliding in a
perfect storm that has rocked his
government mr. Trudeau managed to dodge
the bullet of having to make a cabinet
decision on tech frontier but in the
eyes of some West he is responsible
nonetheless weighing in the CEO of tech
frontier said that what was missing was
a clear framework untainted by politics
that would lay out how the country could
reconcile resource development
with climate change that's something
that mr. Trudeau has not managed to
produce instead there's a failure of a
highly symbolic energy project and also
no plan to meet the Kyoto targets much
less the zero carbon footprint he's
promising mr. Trudeau's commitment to
reconciliation is also on trial with
indigenous leaders condemning today's
OPP arrests and the promise of more
protests and blockades with the slogan
shut down Canada has the business
community warning that there could be
fleeing foreign capital from Canada and
saying more big projects could be
sidelined with the economy being damaged
if there isn't a solution soon but make
no mistake this is not all on the Prime
Minister no other party has proposed a
viable way forward on any of the three
issues there's lots of finger-pointing
but no constructive talk several
premiers refused to bend on the carbon
tax as Heather said and the same goes
for major contenders for the
conservative leadership like Peter
MacKay despite shifting public opinion
on the environment there seems to be a
vacuum of leadership and a plan on all
sides Donna okay
Mercedes Stevenson and Ottawa Thanks the
latest consequences of kovat 19 coming
up the misery it's creating for the
markets and Italian towns are
quarantined
you
an update tonight on the outbreak of
kovin 19 a seventh case has been
confirmed in British Columbia a man in
his 40s is recovering in self-isolation
he's a close contact of a woman who is
diagnosed last week she contracted the
virus in Iran and flew to Vancouver via
Montreal Canada now has 11 confirmed
cases though there is widespread
transmission in some areas of the world
we are not in that position yet but we
are being preparing for that concern
about a widening outbreak was enough to
spook investors today there are fears
quarantine outside China could disrupt
the world economy and US markets
suffered their worst day in more than
two years the Dow Jones lost more than
1,000 points by the time markets closed
Canada's main index the TSX posted a
triple digit loss down nearly 300 points
here's what's going on with the Cova 19
virus the biggest outbreak is still in
China more than 77,000 cases but there
are now rapidly expanding outbreaks in
Japan and in South Korea which now has
more than 800 confirmed cases and now
northern Italy is affected - more than
200 people there are ill six have died
and ten cities are under lockdown and in
Iran there's confusion one lawmaker said
there have been 50 deaths that's much
higher than what the government is
reporting today the head of the World
Health Organization said it is still not
a pandemic but as crystal gyum ancing
reports no one is certain how many cases
remain undetected scarves and masks
spotted all over the famous canals of
Venice covet 19 is spreading in Italy
it's now the worst hit country in Europe
police are blocking roads 2:11 northern
communities isolating roughly 50,000
people a measure similar to the lock
downs and cities in China aimed at
stopping the spread of the virus China
has taken one of the most ancient
strategies for infectious disease
control and rolled out probably the most
ambitious and I would say agile and
aggressive disease containment effort in
history led by Canadian doctor Bruce
Aylward
the World Health Organization special
investigation team has been working in
China for weeks the epidemic there
peaked and plateaued between January
23rd and February 2nd and according to
the w8 show has steadily been declining
since we are not witnessing large-scale
severe disease or death that this virus
have pandemic potential absolutely it
has are we there yet
from our assessment not yet but fears
remain just look at this huge lineup for
masks in South Korea
no one has immunity to covet 19 its new
and scientists can't say of a person
without symptoms can transmit the virus
back in Italy officials say those who
have died have been elderly and had
pre-existing health conditions there are
concerns the virus is being
underreported in some countries a team
with the w-h-o is set to arrive in Iran
on Tuesday more cases are surfacing
there and it's a key point for travel in
the Middle East
crystal gam Ansan Global News London
still ahead the king of the red carpet
headed to prison
you
the American president addressed a
packed stadium in India today more than
100,000 people were there it's Donald
Trump's first official trip to India
he's developed strong ties with India's
Hindu nationalist leader NAND remote II
and this 36-hour trip was filled with
pageantry and photo ops but not a lot of
substance the two countries faced
tensions over trade and are trying to
tighten their security cooperation the
man who used to be known as the king of
Hollywood the movie mogul who could make
or break careers is in jail tonight
Harvey Weinstein has been found guilty
of sex crimes and will now forever be
known as a convicted rapist prosecutors
believe the case surrounding the
disgraced Hollywood producer will change
the way the courts consider other
victims of sexual assault
Jackson Pratt's go on the verdict and
the reaction harvey weinstein displayed
little emotion as the verdict was read
guilty of rape and a criminal sex act
not guilty on three more serious charges
including predatory sexual assault it's
a new day because Harvey Weinstein has
finally been held accountable for crimes
he committed it's a victory for the
dozens of women who've accused the
former Hollywood mogul of sexual
misconduct and assault the conviction
focused specifically on two accusers
Miriam Haley and Jessica man jurors also
had to consider the testimony of four
other women including Annabella Shora
who starred in The Sopranos she claimed
Weinstein raped her in the early 1990s
Weinstein never spoke in his own defense
immediately after the verdict he was led
away in handcuffs to await sentencing I
don't think he was ready to be taken
into custody but he was a gentleman it
was fine the conviction is a watershed
moment for the me2 movement the
accusations against Weinstein launched a
reckoning empowering women everywhere to
speak up against their abusers even the
rich and powerful this is the age of
empowerment of women
and you cannot intimidate them anymore
Weinstein faces up to 25 years in prison
his defense plans to appeal and
prosecutors in Los Angeles are moving
ahead with a second more expansive case
involving four more charges
Jackson pros go Global News Washington
next she was one of the hidden figures
who took the space race to new heights
God knew they couldn't be on this earth
without each other that's Vanessa Bryant
talking about her husband Kobe Bryant
and their thirteen-year-old daughter
Gianna who were killed in a helicopter
crash last month 20-thousand people
filled the Staples Center in Los Angeles
for a public memorial to them including
celebrities and athletes Vanessa Bryant
today also filed a wrongful death
lawsuit against the helicopter operator
involved in the crash that killed the
NBA superstar his daughter and seven
others NASA is mourning the loss of a
pioneer she wasn't an astronaut she was
a mathematician and her work helped
launch the first American into space and
put the first human on the moon
Catherine Johnson also broke down racial
and social barriers along the way
Johnson has passed away at the age of
101 and tonight Mike Armstrong looks at
her incredible legacy the accolades for
Catherine Johnson came late in life but
there were some big ones
this was the Presidential Medal of
Freedom in 2015 there's also NASA's
computational research facility that
bears her name and several honorary
degrees this for a woman who would walk
into meetings and have men assume she
was the maid she was there for the math
the tougher the problem Catherine
Johnson would say the more she enjoyed
it
[Music]
born in West Virginia 1918 Johnson grew
up loving something most might think
strange counting as a young girl whether
it was the number of steps on the street
or steps to school or the colors she'd
washed she counted everything well by 15
she was in university by 18 she had two
degrees
she only attended graduate school but it
was desegregated by court order in 1952
Johnson joined the agency that would
become NASA she was part of a segregated
unit that did computing know the role of
the women in that unit was overlooked
and untold for decades until a book and
then a movie hidden figures they tell
the story of the gender and racial
barriers the women faced but also what
they accomplished Johnson did the
analytic geometry that calculated the
trajectory of the first American in
space and Apollo 11s mission to the moon
there's a scene in the movie where
legendary astronaut John Glenn questions
calculations done by a machine and
demands Johnson go over them Catherine
yes sir
smart one I mean she says they're good
I'm ready to go so you check the
computers numbers and what did you come
up with the same number the computer
head now Johnson did have a trick to
accomplish what she did it was that love
of counting and her passion for numbers
she would say do your best but do what
you love if you don't do what you love
then shame on you what a role model that
is global national for this Monday I'm
Donna freezin tonight's York Canada is
turtle 4 in Saskatchewan we'd love to
see your Canada please email it to us
and thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow bye
bye
[Music]
you